joining me now is Ari Fleischer former
White House Press Secretary as well as
kellyanne Conway former senior counsel
to president Trump both are Fox News
contributors kellyanne I know you
remember this trip to Puerto Rico you
might as well have thought that that you
know Melania had said something
incredibly cruel to the victims of the
Hurricanes there but they stayed on that
story about her coat for I think this
went on for almost two weeks
well the message on her coat was at the
border yeah and it occurred after she
had been at the border visiting with
children but that was for the mainstream
media that aside this is the essence of
who Joe Biden is he got elected in 2020
on a false premise I'm a moderate on a
unifier I'm compassionate I get the job
done empathetic I've been in government
for half a century therefore I can
dispense resources to people in need
like if they ever suffer from the
America's greatest fire in Maui but I
don't want to excuse his conduct Lara
I'm sick of people saying these are
gaffes that he exaggerates he
embellishes these are flat out lies and
who is around him to stop him you know
how long of a flight it is to Hawaii we
all know that tell the guy hey don't
mention the house fire thing again like
he did in October 2022 when people were
suffering from a hurricane because it
made no sense and it's a lie the other
thing to note about Joe Biden on this is
the gold star mom I think this is the
one that really has people upset the
gold star mom made a gold star mom
because of his chaotic and irrational
withdrawal from Afghanistan two years
ago this month
she said her heart started beating fast
and she started just staring into space
because he said to her Jill and I know
something about your loss our son also
came home in a flake drive a flake a
flag trade coffin excuse me it is tragic
that Beau Biden died of cancer but as
the gold star mom said he didn't die in
combat he died of cancer in Delaware
that is tragic no doubt but she said at
least you had a chance to be with him at
the end you robbed us of that chance so
he lies for the sake of lying and by the
way when you're a leader especially
president United States Ari knows this
he was there can you use the word I a
lot less than Joe Biden does yeah I
think all politicians need to do that
Ari
um Biden's trip was covered by CNN this
way
he did serve as empathizer in chief
after five days of being mostly silent
on the issue publicly but the governor
said he was working behind the scenes to
assure First Responders that the feds
had their back on this he shared the
stories we're familiar with of losing
his daughter and wife and wondering if
his sons had survived a car accident
early in his political career and that's
what so many people here are going
through now
Ari this is so Brazen at this point I
mean the lies keep piling up and the
media know their lies or they're totally
ignorant and they never call him on it
this is this is astounding
yeah Lord what bothers me so much is Joe
Biden is not an empathetic man he's a
selfish man he's a selfish man an old
man who all he knows how to do is press
play he presses play on the same old
broken Tunes he's been telling for
decades it doesn't matter what the
circumstance is and when someone is in
the middle of bereavement you know what
they want to hear they don't want to
hear that you also had something they
don't want to hear you compare your
tragedy even if it's a kitchen fire to
their real fire
they want to hear about you they want
you to express there's something about
what they're going through their loss
not your chat not your Corvette that's
what they want to hear from the
president and as for him comparing it to
his house fire I was thinking that'd be
like on September 11th George Bush or me
saying that I understand what the
nation's going through because somebody
once broke onto my front porch and stole
the package
you know Joe Biden is just out of touch
with what people think if he thinks it's
about himself and his kitchen fire but
kellyanne I think this is uh really
speaks to the overall Narrative of Lies
you know it's always Trump's big lie
that's all you hear about from the media
Trump's big lie but these are a series
of lies about personal tragedies about
the economy about how well things were
going in Ukraine and apparently not very
well sadly
um and the lies keep piling up
and now the American people are left
with what an election where they're
going to try to I don't know put
everyone in Mass again and send out
mail-in ballots I mean this is where we
are
well it's good Republicans are going to
invest in what I call the non-sexy parts
of politics Ari and Laura which are the
mechanics because you look at Joe Biden
and Kamala Harris Sean fetterman the
Democrats have no interest in elevating
and electing quality human beings to
high office they have an interest in
power in keeping it so they don't tell
us why to vote philosophically or even
for whom but where how and when on Joe
Biden people need to remember this he
needs to be held to account and I think
every Democrat should be made to eat and
own what you saw yesterday in Maui
complete disgrace as well as all the
policies I have a little bit more faith
because if you look at all the polls not
only is Joe Biden and Kamala Harris even
less popular and he if you could believe
it not only are they underwater with
their approval ratings Lara but they're
Underwood on every major issue there's
no one issue and no one attribute cares
about people like me is compassion it
has a plan understands the middle class
there's no one attribute where he really
can stake a claim and say that's the
rationale for re-election this is the
first presidential election where Joe
Biden in full will be litigated by the
voters and that's why he'll lose
hey Ari on this debate tomorrow night
that's going to be on Fox Trump's
obviously not going to be there
um do you think that if you were
advising him uh would you advise him to
not attend because he's so far up in the
polls why give Chris Christie the chance
to be the punching uh you know you know
him being the punching bag uh or would
you say Go and show you know show your
record and show who you are what would
you say
yeah for for the primary purposes it'd
be political malpractice for Donald
Trump to show up he has a 40 50 point
lead over his opponents there's nothing
to be gained for Donald Trump showing up
in a primary the problem he'll have
though is what you really want as
Republicans to get almost 82 year old
Joe Biden on stage next year and if the
president is set that Donald Trump
didn't debate so why should I we'll say
Joe Biden next fall then Donald Trump's
got an inconsistency problem to deal
with if he's the nominee if it was good
enough for him to skip well it could be
good enough for Biden and as somebody
who wants America to be exposed to what
an 82 year old bumbler looks like
nothing's more important than getting
Joe Biden on that stage not giving him
an excuse so there's two sides to it
Laura I get the short-term side but
there's a long-term damage he's doing by
not showing up at least for the first
one
thing I hadn't thought
of debate whoever the Republican nominee
is next year yes or no Willie
they were no he won't they won't let him
out there they hardly let him out there
at all we don't see much of him and and
when we do and you see and maybe it
would even mean Kamala doesn't have to
debate which of course they'd want to
avoid also because she battles a
teleprompter every day and the
telepopter wins she doesn't put in the
work so I can't imagine her debating
another human being on policy and
substance in her record but that would
be terrible I believe debates are part
of the democratic process and we the
people deserve to see those voters
engage with each other free of charge
and instantly
Ari and kellyanne great to see you both
thank you hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else